[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá pessoal
eu vim como o último explica pra contar
uma história muito breve para vocês
e essa história começa nos anos 80 eu
sou uma criança nos anos 80
eu nasci no interior de santa catarina e
eu desde muito cedo costumava passar as
minhas férias escolares na casa de um
tio que eu amava muito até hoje esse tio
tinha um grande ativo para uma criança
nos anos 80 ele trabalhava no rádio e
desde muito cedo e se meu tio me levou
para o rádio
junto com ele eu ia lá pra tocar discos
de vinil né e trocar na época os
cartuchos que eram cartuchos enorme de
propaganda
os comerciais que passavam no rádio ele
me deixava operando a mesa e aquilo por
uma criança nos anos 80 uma coisa
incrível ainda mais com a criança como
eu que era sempre foi aficionado por
tecnologia
quando eu voltei do meu último verão que
eu passei com ele ele falou pra mim olha
o que você não faz um jornalzinho na
sociedade como eu faço aqui na minha ele
tinha um jornal impresso em folha a3 que
no jornal enorme desse tamanho que ele
colocava entre o plástico ea toalha das
mesas de pizzarias chamava o butiquim eu
voltei para minha cidade e do
adolescente resolvi fazer o butiquim e
fiz o butiquim imprimir aquele jornal e
comecei a distribuir pela minha cidade e
vender espaços publicitários
um belo dia um amigo me ligou e falou o
cara vem aqui em casa que eu preciso
mostrar uma coisa pra você
ele trabalhava com publicidade eu
cheguei na casa dele o computador dele
estava ligado
já tinha passado da meia noite e ele
mostrou à internet e aquilo foi um
negócio absolutamente incrível para mim
que mudou minha vida de maneira
avassaladora
quando eu decidir o que eu queria fazer
de fato da minha vida que era ser
jornalista eu não tinha idéia de que
existe a faculdade de jornalismo
aí depois eu descobri isso e acabei indo
pra estudar jornalismo
no início dos anos 2000 a grande coisa
que existia na época do pará jornalistas
eram os logs e os blogs eram o que
poderia revolucionar a a comunicação na
época principalmente o jornalismo eu
descobri muitos e dos blogs vira um
blogueiro e imaginei que aquilo
e também mudar o mundo assim como eu
também um outro blogueiro imaginou que
os blogs eo mudar o mundo
um jornalista iraniano chamado hosein
derakhshan você era o maior blogueiro do
irã um país onde há necessidade de
evolução de comunicação existia e existe
até hoje ele era chamado de blog fazer
porque ele foi de fato o primeiro
blogueiro primeiro grande porque
blogueiro do país
rossen continuou escrevendo no seu
blogue até 2008 quando ele foi preso
justamente pelas coisas que ele escrevia
naquele blog ele era dissidente e acabou
sendo encarcerado em 2014 quando você
saiu da cadeia
ele voltou para o apartamento onde ele
morava no centro de teerã plugou
internet pela primeira vez ao longo de
todos aqueles anos quando ele não teve
acesso à internet e descobriu que a
internet que eu conheci e que você
conheceu no final dos anos 90 e início
dos anos 2000 tinha mudado para sempre
a era dos blogs tinha acabado a era dos
links tinha acabado
aquela idéia dos primeiros teóricos da
comunicação de que nós estaremos diante
da nova biblioteca de alexandria havia
erodido justamente por causa da criação
das plataformas e das redes sociais ou
sem ficou absolutamente espantado como
as pessoas começaram a imaginar que a
internet era apenas uma duas ou três
redes sociais e ele viu que as pessoas
não navegavam mais pra lugar nenhum ela
são mais blog ela não tinha mais o
hábito de acessar sites fora das redes
sociais
e aí eu vou sem descobriu o stream ou
como a gente conhece no brasil o feed
o jornalismo passou a habitar um lugar
que ele não habitava antes que é a alma
da nossa mão nos celulares
competindo com o entretenimento com
notícias banais com notícias falsas e
com fofocas sobre os nossos vizinhos
aquilo de fato na época por você em
significou um grande problema e esse
problema nos levou onde a gente está
hoje o jornalismo acabou sendo destruído
também por causa do streaming e por
causa dos seus algoritmos
hoje nós não temos mais o hábito de
navegar em vários sites e buscar
informação em outros lugares
abrir a nossa cabeça e mudar a nossa
concepção de mundo
a gente recebe relatados pré-prontos
todos os dias na palma da nossa mão que
são enviados por algoritmos secretos
cujas formas a gente não conhece e cujo
teor e cujos objetivos a gente não tem
acesso
isso acabou fazendo com que o jornalismo
junto com todo esse caldeirão que de
revolução que o mundo passou pelos
últimos anos sofresse uma queda brusca
de confiança
as últimas pesquisas sobre confiança na
imprensa no brasil são absolutamente
aterradoras 10% das pessoas no brasil
jovens confiam muito no que sai na
imprensa
ou seja nove entre cada dez jovens
brasileiros não confiam na imprensa
existe uma responsabilidade da imprensa
nisso porque por muitos anos ignorou
público e ignorou transparência mas
existe uma responsabilidade também das
plataformas das redes sociais e de seus
algoritmos obscuros
esse é um cenário absolutamente
aterrador para todo mundo não só para
quem vive de informação mas para quem
consome informação
nós temos hoje os nossos dados sendo
vendidos traficados e roubados nas
plataformas sociais e na internet em
geral ea gente não sabe como esses dados
são manipulados por quem esses dados são
manipulados
o buraco da fechadura que nós
conseguimos vislumbrar os últimos anos
mostram que empresas de inteligência
usando os dados que eventualmente nós
sequer fornecemos usam esses dados para
manipular eleições e para cometer
atrocidades pelo mundo
os exemplos são vários e vocês podem
encontrar eles na internet muito
facilmente
eu vim aqui hoje para falar sobre
jornalismo para falar do que eu gosto
pra falar do que eu sei fazer o
jornalismo sempre foi uma coisa que me
emocionou desde o começo porque era a
capacidade que eu tinha de mudar a vida
das pessoas
então esse cenário catastrófico que hoje
nós vivemos e que nós sentimos que o
público sente a máquina de lama
o assassinato de reputações o medo as
ameaças que nós jornalistas sofremos
todos os dias
ele é um cenário sim catastrófico mas
não acredito e não quero acreditar que
ele seja um cenário apocalíptico eu
tenho muita fé e muita esperança no
futuro eu acho que daqui a 20 ou 30 anos
nós vamos olhar o passado e vamos ver
que os veículos que nós estaremos
consumindo daqui a 30 anos são os
veículos que nós estamos criando hoje
aqui no brasil e no mundo todo
essa é a nossa revolução esse é o
momento que a gente tem pra fazer isso
então pra que essa nova comunicação
aconteça nós temos a responsabilidade
também de ajudar a salvar a internet
porque a internet está assim há perigo
nós todos estamos há perigo quando
consumimos informação relatada e não
confiável
nós todos estamos há perigo quando
apenas um entre nove e dez jovens
confiam que sai na imprensa porque são
esses jovens que vão ser os votantes do
futuro e que vão definir o futuro da
nossa democracia e ao fim ao cabo das
nossas vidas
eu acredito sim que a gente precisa
olhar o jornalismo como um momento
revolucionário e precisa mudar a maneira
como a gente pensa o nosso próprio
ofício
então eu queria dizer pra vocês algo que
eu digo pra mim a redação todos os dias
e algo que eu digo todas as vezes que eu
tenho a oportunidade de falar em público
nós precisamos de um jornalismo mais
transparente nós precisamos conversar
com as pessoas
nós precisamos entender que o brasil é
um país onde 70% das pessoas têm uma
incapacidade absoluta de ler e
compreender e decodificar um texto
simples eu peço todos os dias dos meus
colegas jornalistas
por favor parem de usar clichês a gente
precisa reorganizar a linguagem
jornalística pará de simplesmente levar
adiante para os nossos leitores do nosso
público o que os burocratas falam a
linguagem burocrática foi criada por
burocratas pra mentir para as pessoas
nós não podemos fazer com que as pessoas
sejam enganadas
através da nossa pena dos nossos jornais
dos nossos sites da nossa comunicação e
da nossa voz
essa revolução que acredito no
jornalismo essa revolução que eu
acredito que a agente precisa no brasil
e no mundo pra ter uma democracia melhor
e pra ter de fato uma democracia no
futuro
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]